we have chairs stashed under the under
the table so when we have a good sized
off-air event we can move everything
around that's bill Petrocelli he's one
of the co-owners of the book store book
passage we are in the Ferry Building in
San Francisco which is probably the most
exciting venue for activity and market
and for visitors in the city I just
pulled this without to show you saw the
shelf that's my own book I wrote this
four years ago now it's called circle of
thirteen and it's a novel petroselli
stories have the uneventful Saur fans
book passage says it holds about 800 of
these events per year between its stores
and special events around the Bay Area
if you're keeping track that's a lot of
autographed books yes I think the best
part of the book business when they'll
offer em a read or get together in your
store have a little discussion it's
wonderful everything seemed fine for
Petrocelli and its business until a
curious new law passed in California
regulating autograph signings now
something is finally being done starting
January 1st any autograph collectible
sold in California must come with a
certificate of authenticity the law was
meant to crack down on autograph fakers
who do customers but critics say it's
much more it's a certificate of
authenticity requirement on steroids
which essentially requires you know all
this information is very difficult to
comply with let's petrocelli's attorney
on a stage of bowden with the Pacific
Legal Foundation she's helping him sue
the state over the law saying it
violates petrocelli's freedom of speech
because it forces him to keep track of a
burdensome amount of information and
that includes details about the sale the
date the time the place the amount of
money whether the seller is bonded if
the book was signed in front of the
person eyewitness to the signing and
their personal details if the book was
obtained secondhand the name of the
previous owner anything that requires
extra paperwork is going to drive up the
cost of doing business this is a
children's section back here and it's
children it comes a lot of events to see
their favorite author want their book
signed we could save it all there and if
we're going to have to go through
record-keeping to keep track of every of
every child device book I mean top of
everything else in the basis our prices
it's just crazy the sellers also have to
keep a copy of
record for seven years or face costly
penalties a civil court could reward
Dukes customers as much as ten times the
original cost of the faked item if a
book is a rare limited-edition and more
expensive the bookseller could be on the
hook for the price of the book and ten
times the price of the book on top of
that and that's not all
anybody continued to enforce the law and
get court costs attorney's fees interest
expert witness fees and any relief
support fines appropriate this law just
it's like I just drop on a farm in the
middle of it that's terrible but why
would anyone pass a law for such an
inconsequential issue like fake
autographs that is a story from a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away I'm
sure I walk around here arresting you
Rihanna and Mark Hamill for his role as
Luke Skywalker battling the Galactic
Empire in the Star Wars movie
yep the classic tale of when politicians
came up with celebrities this law
originated as any law does and that is
with somebody with a lot of political
clout and a sob story and so in this
case it was Mark Hamill aka Luke
Skywalker who had the sob story that
people were being swindled out of quote
hundreds of dollars for buying fake Mark
Hamill autographs so he approached the
legislature and said we need a law for
that I've heard a couple of stories that
just break your heart because there's no
way to compensate them a couple of
people I've actually sought out and sent
real autographs and what came of it was
this love the politician behind the
autograph law was Assemblywoman Ling
Ling Chang her bill flew through the
California Legislature and a breeze then
books always kind of got word of this
and looked at my god this could apply to
autographed books right on the face of
it but when Petrocelli tried to get the
bill fixed things got worse and when we
approached our local people are local
assemblyman and all that and say you
know you got to do something they said
well you got to go back to the author of
the bill and maybe in the next session
she'll introduce a bill correcting it we
said she lost in the last election she's
not there so what he's got to take
responsibility for this Chang chose not
to sit down with us for an interview but
did tell us via email that she stands by
the bill she also said the booksellers
were exempt for maybe 1570 because the
law says the dealer must be principally
in the
of selling collectibles but Bowden says
the word principally here is vague and
arguably Petrocelli is principally
engaged in selling autographed books in
addition to holding hundreds of events
with autograph signings every year book
passage even has a first edition
autographed book club you can join so
this is how he's innovated in the age of
Amazon Kindle she also says the
potential penalties in the autograph law
are so high that they may scare people
away from engaging in protected speech
signatures are protected by the First
Amendment
owning a signature that means something
to somebody I think that's expression
the chain may not be the only politician
out there that doesn't understand the
consequences of passing vague laws a
bill in the assembly has popped up that
tries to fix the damage that Shanksville
caused
assembly bill 228 it exempts items from
the law that sell for less than $50 but
that doesn't help Petrocelli it doesn't
give him any relief you know he sold
books that are worth over $50 all the
time also there's this tiny detail a B
228 limits the autograph law to sports
and entertainment memorabilia but if you
take a look around Petrocelli store you
can see he has entertainment and sports
books for sale on the day we visited he
was even advertising a book signing for
one and if that isn't troubling enough
think about this book passage recently
hosted an event where Caitlyn Jenner
came and promoted her biography and
Caitlyn Jenner was formerly a sports
star and is also now an entertainment
star and so it would seem that her book
still qualifies for this autograph law
and a B to 20 really does nothing for
Bill in that case that's a perfect
example is Kate was is the Caitlyn
Jenner biography a sports book or not it
kind of depends on how you think about
it and yes if you have to make that kind
of decision on every single book in the
store it'll drive you crazy there is
another bill that could protect
Petrocelli Senate bill 579 right now the
Senate bill actually looks fairly good
it does at this moment it seeks to
exempt book but it's not the one getting
any of the publicity the one that's
getting all the publicity is a B 228
which is you know backed by Barnes &
Noble and antiquarian book sellers and
then people like that meanwhile this
little old bill in the Senate that
actually would do some good is supported
by the auctioneers and that one seems to
not be getting any attention at all
[Music]
petracelli seems to be in a holding
pattern until something happens with his
lawsuit or until one of the new bills
gets passed if they ever do but he's not
taking his tenuous situation lying down
in fact we caught him in the middle of
an illegal act against the state before
we left his store I managed to talk you
into getting a copy of my book which is
here which is one of the many books we
sell I'll do what I'm doing right here
which is put a little inscription on it
- Paul thanks for everything it's really
too bad we won't ever know if his
autograph is real
[Music]